well as we enter the new year local
leaders are focusing on supporting local
businesses through the pandemic and
bringing
the new ones to town today 310 nutrition
opened on rainbow and warm springs in
the southwest valley 8 news now reporter
katie houston joins us live in the
newsroom tonight
with more on the economic growth in that
area kate
yes we're only a few days into 2021 and
new businesses are already popping up
around town
commissioner michael naft who represents
district a in the southwest valley
tells me there's quite a bit of
confidence in the community when it
comes to developing new businesses
and growing the economy out of a ribbon
310 nutrition officially opened its
first brick and mortar store
located in the southwest valley this is
all about building community we want
people to have what they need right as
close as possible and this is going to
be a big part of that commissioner
michael naft joined the founder of 310
nutrition tim sharif
to welcome the new business which offers
smoothies supplements and wellness
support
it was originally based in los angeles
and grew its clientele on social media
when it came time to pick a retail
location
sharif says las vegas was his top choice
when the time was right and my business
was going i came back to the best place
to be an entrepreneur and this is the
place
that really supports community and
business for me over the past few years
the southwest valley has seen many new
business and housing developments
commissioner naft says part of his
district near 215 and rainbow
is becoming the new center of the valley
despite economic hardship over the past
year
naft says having businesses like 310
nutrition open their doors
is a good sign for the recovery of the
city there's still a lot of
optimism here in our community and for
our economy there's still going to be a
lot of growth everybody's adapting to
the new world and the new way we do
business
but there's going to be a lot of success
in that as well commissioner naft says
one of his focuses for 2021
is to support local businesses to ensure
they can keep their doors open
and prosper in the new year and for
those that want to open a business
or do have one but need some help
commissioner naft is encouraging them to
reach out to the county
or his office for support